RESPONSE TO THE CODE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC BECAUSE THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT. NONESSENTIAL
GALLERIES IN HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING A FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH. OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS ME
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. PLEASE SIGN ON THE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME. TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
JURY AND THAT TIME HAS BEEN
DETERMINED AS FOLLOWS LEAD
WITNESSES WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
FOR EACH WITNESS AND THERE'S NO
RESERVING TIME FOR OTHER
WITNESSES. ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY THIS LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME THEIR
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. FOR THOSE WITNESSES
ARE GOING TO BE A TIME LIMIT OF
TEN MINUTES TOTAL PER SUPPORT
IN TEN MINUTES TOTAL FOR
OPPOSITION. TO VOTE A PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
THE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. A PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
877-226-8189. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE EIGHT
NINE THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO
EIGHT SEVEN SIX ZERO FIVE NINE.
TWO EIGHT SEVEN SIX ZERO FIVE
NINE FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TEAM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE. OR THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY
A MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER
BECAUSE THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER HE WILL WEIGH IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
CALL YOUR LINE. AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE A MUTED AND YOU'RE
THEN READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING AND
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT.
SO ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
BE HEARD. WE HAVE ONE BILL ON
TODAY'S AGENDA AB SIX FIFTY
FOUR OF THE RATE IS BILL IN
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATION ON
THE BILL LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTER PROTESTING. FOR TESTING
HERE BUT CHOI BOOK A TROUBLE
HERE THE RUSSELL THE RUSSELL
HERE LAYERED HERE LEAD HERE
NEWMAN HERE NEWMAN HERE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM IN NOW WE'RE GONNA HEAR
FROM SENATOR WHO A MOMENT WHO
WILL BE PRESENTING THIS BILL ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
TODAY PRESENT TO YOU AB SIX
FIVE FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES WHICH IS A CLEAN A BILL
TO A PREVIOUS MEASURE SHE HAD
AB SIXTY FIVE. WHICH FOCUSED ON
THE BASIC STEPS EMPLOYERS MUST
TAKE TO CONTROL WORK SITE
SPECIFIC EXPOSURE OF COVE IN
NINETEEN. CLEAN UP TO THIS
MASSIVE MEASURE IS ESSENTIAL TO
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT WE CAN
MITIGATE THE EFFECTS OF THE
PANDEMIC. RECENT AMENDMENTS
REMOVE ALL OPPOSITION AND EVEN
MOVED THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND OTHERS THAT WERE IN
OPPOSITION TO A SUPPORT
POSITION HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS A JESSE GREWAL
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR U. F.
C. W. WESTERN STATE COUNCIL AND
ROBERT TREAT. A POLICY ADVOCATE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. THANK THANK YOU IN
THE ROB MYSTERY- I UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE HERE IN PERSON IF YOU
LIKE TO STEP FORWARD AND-
TESTIFY YOU MAY DO SO AT THIS
TIME RIGHT THERE IS FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU COUNSEL- RUBBER
TRIPLEPOINT CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
JUST VERY BRIEFLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS GOOD CLEAN UP LEGISLATION
AND GLAD ANSWER QUESTIONS BUT
DON'T TAKE MORE TIME AND I
BELIEVE JAZZY THE SPONSOR IS
ALSO. GREAT AGAIN JESSE GREW
WILL IS ON THE COAST LINE AS
WILL NOW GO TO JUST AGREE HALL
IF YOU CAN HEAR US SO PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND COMMIT YOUR TESTIMONY.
YES THANK YOU I DIDN'T INTEND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DOES HE GROW ALL LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR WITH U. S. B. W. L. ON
BEHALF OF OUR FRONT LINE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS THANK YOU FOR
HEARING THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
WHICH OFFERS NECESSARY
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP. THE LAST
YEAR'S EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE. TO OTHER
TESTIMONY ON THE SUPPORT SIDE.
A WE DO NOT HAVE AN OVERFLOW
ROOM TODAY BUT LET ME ASK
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT. OF THIS
BILL OTHER THAN THE LEAD
WITNESSES WE ALREADY HEARD
FROM. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIX FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU AND APPRECIATE
THE- EARNS TO THE RULES THIS
PORTION. OF THE TESTIMONY IS
FOR YOU YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION AND OF YOUR
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION THE BILL.
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO.
EXPRESS THEIR VIEWS ASSENAGON
BEGIN WE HAVE NO OVERFLOW ROOM
TODAY UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES
WE ARE GOING TO GO TO THE
MODERATOR NESS MODERATOR. TO
QUEUE UP OF ANY. A SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON THE TELECONFERENCE
FIGHTS THANK YOU. ALRIGHT IF
YOU WERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE LINE. GLOBAL WARMING
ARE GOING TO BE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IT ASKING INVESTOR JERRY
MEMBERS STATEOR JUST ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY IN
THE FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
A CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY AND
MARK. LONG LINE NUMBER TWENTY
SIX ONE TWENTY SIX ELIZABETH.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MEGAN TWO BIRDS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLANS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT. ONE
NUMBER TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIGURE
OUT YOUR MEMBERS CHALLENGING ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WELL NOW ON
LINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KEVIN
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE LINE
NUMER TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHANGE
FILTER HERE ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
RISK INNOVATION SOLUTIONS IN
MANAGEMENT STRONG SUPPORT. I.
ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HE'S GOING TO. GOOD AFTERNOON
RYAN IS THAT WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A CALL. OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR- WILL NOW- TURNED TO
ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY ON
THIS BUILDER THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS IDENTIFIED-
BUT LET ME ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE ROOM IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM. IF SO
PLEASE STEP FORWARD I'M SEEN
NONE. AGAIN OF FOR THOSE
FAMILIAR WITH PROTOCOL WE HAVE
NO OVERFLOW ROOM TODAY BUT WE
WILL GO TO THE MODERATOR DOWN
S. MODERATOR TO QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. ON THIS
BILL AB SIX FIFTY FOUR. WELL
ONE FOUR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
GIDGET'S WANTED GERMAN OPERATOR
WILL DELIGHT AFTER. NO ONE'S
HAVE TEAMED UP PROPOSITIONS
PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR APPRECIATE YOU
CHECKING THEM WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE NOW AS NOTED WE
OF A QUORUM AND- SHARE IN OUR
VICE SHURA CENTER CHILL BOGU
WE ARE HERE. ANYONE WISH TO-
COMMENT OR ASK QUESTIONS ON
THIS BILL. I'M HAPPY TO MOVE
THE BILL. CENTER NEWMAN- WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL- YOU HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY CLOSE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- KEY- IN WITH THAT WAS
CONSOLED TO TAKE A ROLL CALL
VOTE PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS COURTESY HI COURTESY I OR
TO EVOKE. A TROUBLED I WOULD
WRESTLE. THE REST SO I LAYERED
AYE LAYERED AYE NEWMAN. NEWMAN
AYE. THE PASSES- FIVE ZERO
UNANIMOUS VOTE THE BILL IS OUT
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
FOR A PRESENTING IT LET ME
JUST- AGAIN I DID THIS LAST THE
LAST COMMITTEE MEETING- IN A
DIFFERENT WAY BUT IF I CAN-
EXERCISE A PROGRAM OF THE
CHAIR- I FILLED WITH A
KNOWLEDGE THE ENTIRE- COMMITTEE
STUFF. IN THE IN MY OWN STUFF
LAST TIME- I KNOW THAT EACH
MEMBER OF YOUR KNOWLEDGE IS
THEIR OWN STAFFS INCLUDING THE
VICE CHAIR FOR THEIR WORK
INDIVIDUALLY IN THEIR OFFICES
IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF. I DON'T
THINK I MENTION MARKETERS LAST
TIME IT I DON'T KNOW THAT SHE'S
HERE- THERE SHE IS MARTHA THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL YOUR
EFFORTS- DURING THE. COURSE OF
YOUR NEW PATIENT VERY MUCH. IN
WITH THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED
THANK YOU.